i mean you play these roles i mean these
intense roles you're either
heroic or you're this villain or what do
you prefer because you're a funny guy do
you want to play more comedic roles
because you have that comedic charm even
even in a peacemaker yeah well the james
is is uh
the gateway i mean he's the one that
kind of unleashed that and gave me the
opportunity to kind of have fun with
that and i'm also getting more confident
in myself as a performer that i think i
can do more and more things it's a
complex what you're talking about is
very comp it's it's to me it's very
layered um
i think i'm in a unique situation
because of the way i came up in the
business i came up as a guy that started
with roger corman i could do my own
stunts i could fight i happened to be
fairly suitable looking for the camera
and i kind of worked my way in that way
you know what i'm saying yeah and uh i
have a street cred and sort of something
to back it up right and
and that overcame my lack of formal
training
you didn't really have that much
training no no no no no i came out here
i lived in my car for a couple couple
weeks uh i didn't know anybody i didn't
have an agent what year is this 1984. 84
you came out here live in your car you
didn't have an agent and by the way i
hear that you like i read somewhere you
didn't even want to act when you were
younger like you didn't really have it
like well yeah you did you've done some
great research
dug deep um well my first acting
experience uh it was my mother uh uh who
kind of got me doing like some print ads
in georgia for like rich's department
store but i was chosen to be peter pan
and play in third grade and i was kind
of embarrassed about that and the guys
and then there was the question of you
got to wear the tights and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
i don't think so it'll be green
corduroys for me and uh you know at
third grade i think that you know what
what what year was it 67 or something
like that i did i did peter pan and you
know what i loved it
really i mean i as far as i can think
back to my mind
uh what i was thinking at however old i
was just an excitement i loved it i
jumped out on stage hi i'm peter band
from never never like you played peter
pan i was peter
it was just a school play but i think it
was enough michael that it it it kind of
made me go acting
right and you remember when i grew up
well you don't remember but i mean
i grew up in a time
when you didn't have this
i know you didn't have games
you didn't have any of that [ __ ] yeah
you had a baseball you had a football
you had a gun
you had a gun yeah yeah how old were you
when you had a baby guns oh okay little
baby you you you had you had the woods
right oh yeah you had a dog you had some
friends you had a bike and you went out
and created your fun that's true and you
acted